depuis leur création en allemagne il ya
presque cent ans les gars me berg
contiennent soit de la gomme arabique ou
de la gélatine d'origine animale mais
signe des temps certains deviennent
aujourd'hui végétalienne moi ce que j'ai
fait dans mes deux je sais que j'ai
simplement pris les purées de fruits
naturels
les bonbons gélifiés végétalien ne
contiennent pas de gélatine ni aucun
autre produit dérivé d'un animal d'un
poisson ou d'un insecte ont prêté et
pose un défi des jours sombres et la
pectine de l'agar agar ou la fécule de
maïs par contre j'ai une petite
préférence je vous dirai pour la fécule
de maïs qui est beaucoup plus accessible
et moins dispendieuse les saveurs les
formes et les couleurs sont semblables
aux friandises traditionnels c'est dans
la texture qu'on remarque une différence
l'agar agar va être beaucoup plus de
casse en d'aller voir là dedans il se
comporte pas de la même façon que les
autres la fécule de maïs vaudront plus
tendres vrais fruits sans gluten sans
ogm sans gras trans végétaliens ou
végétariens et un bon bon ça reste un
bonbon quand on regarde la liste des
gazons d'hébron conventionnelles comme
les bonbons végétalien le premier regret
dit à cbc crème c'est pas plus en paix
c'est pas qu'une utilité les teneurs en
sucre sont aussi très élevé dans les
moments végétalien on pourrait vouloir
acheter bon végétalien seulement pour
essayer d'avoir un impact un peu moins
important sur la planète pu aussi en
termes d'ingrédients parfois ils
m'accusent des colorants qui sont plus
naturels
[Musique]
on va utiliser par exemple ça peut être
de la betterave du curcumin des choses
qui vont colorer aussi naturellement nos
bonbons et que c'est ça qui va faire en
effet que ans va se démarquer un petit
peu des bonbons plus traditionnelles
qu'on peut trouver à l'épicerie
l'entreprise montréalaise c'qui ch
propose une grande variété de bonbons
végétalien ça permet d'offrir un peu
plus de moments différents à des
communautés aussi comme des communautés
musulmanes qui sont vraiment contents de
pouvoir avoir des bonbons qu'ils peuvent
manger puisque on a retiré la gélatine
de porc animal dedans
malgré les apparences les différentes
compagnies québécoises ou canadiennes ne
fabrique pas leurs bonbons en gelée
puisqu'il n'existe aucune usine de ce
type au canada mais bon goût viennent
essentiellement d'europe d'allemagne
puisque c'est le concret allegheny peu
ils sont à la base des bonbons des juges
une toute l'expertisé est vraiment la
base en europe nous en tant que
compagnie québécoise montréalaise bien
on travaille beaucoup en allemagne aussi
pour des bonbons légèrement plus santé
on peut toujours le faire à la maison
c'est à ce sens avec les fon aussi pour
l'activité en soi donc si on s'assied
les enfants que l'on prend le temps de
faire nos propres jeux chop c'est super
intéressant
une purée de fruits ou même du jus un
agent gélifiants et évidemment du sucre
ont produit environ jusqu'à trois
patineurs ensuite par contre j'avoue son
réveil jusqu'à ce point là les jupes
sont moins sucré en termes de ça va on
va vraiment pu percevoir la différence
pour ce qui est des purées de fruits
gérer en plus la furie j'ajoute est
encore là du fait qu verra donc c'est
vraiment le détour et surgelés ou
pourrait prendre des fruits frais aussi
et là on va acheter les titres à bord
j'ai mis un petit peu de jus des
mustangs version pour avoir un petit
côté exotique indiqué lui aussi qu on va
acheter la gare dans notre opération on
ajoute l'agent gélifiant à la
préparation va faire chauffer et ensuite
c'est vraiment ça qu'on est obligé la
part dans un petit moule en silicone on
lire ça lorsque son génie fait et c'est
tout c'est vraiment ultra ultra simple
et l'autre décidé de combiner exactement
c'est ça la différence c'est qu'on peut
en même temps voir que ça fonctionne
avec n'importe quel prix
sélection de l'atv taf avec les enfants
vont comprendre ce que sait faire des
bonbons à la maison avec des ingrédients
de qualité
ici on celui à base de jus de cerise
avec le sirop d'érable
l'équipe hôte hommes c'est bien mignon
c'est ça c'est la même qu'on ait fait
tantôt d'anthony informant un peu plus
grand et à fraises et celui que je
remercie si ça va être celui avec du jus
d'orange du cambodge à mâcon pour garder
des bénéfices du combo tchèque voilà
j'étais plus tard mon papa de chauffer
les jours sont comme butcher mais qui
l'eût cru ouais on est dans un autre
univers embauché pour pas penser qu'on
va retrouver le goût de de distorsion
aux produits conventionnels à moins
d'utiliser de la pectine l'on va se
rapprocher un peu graphiquement si on
regarde si j'en avais pas tous avec la
fécule de maïs mais j'ai mis un petit
peu le moins donc est vraiment plus il
rebondit beaucoup plus lit plus gély
film est signé par ferme ferme ferme moi
je trouve que la fécule de maïs me donne
quelque chose qui est peu moins
dépaysant un bouge donc agar agar fécule
de maïs personne les trois options
disponibles qu'on peut avoir à la maison
[Musique]